we are fortunate that a nuclear accident
has not yet happened as I said at the
iaea Board of Governors
last March we are rolling a dice
and if this continues then once they our
luck will run out
so we must
all do everything in our power to
minimize the chance that it does
as the council knows since returning
from my first of two missions to the
support nuclear power plant last
September I have been urging all parties
to protect the nuclear Safety and
Security of the plant
this has involved numerous meetings
intensive consultations and exchanges
including at the highest levels in
Ukraine and the Russian Federation